jack miller hat uns gefragt wie wir uns
im sommer kühl halten können bitteschön
sextipps sonne hitze und kein schatten
in sicht hier sind 61 tipps zum cool
bleiben erstens hände weg vom deo was ja
zumindest hände weg von
antitranspirantien die blockiere nämlich
den schweiß
schwitzen ist unsere effektivste
maßnahme gegen überhitzen beim
verdampfen des weißes pferd verdampfung
energie benötigt was in form von wärme
abgezogen wird was wiederum seine
abkühlung führt stattdessen reine
deodorant ihn benutzen die lassen den
schweiß raus sorgen bloß dafür dass er
nicht stinkt funktion von dios habe ich
schon mal ein video gemacht da gibt es
hier zweitens die richtigen klamotten
viele klamotten sind gut dass sie das
sonnenlicht reflektieren aber auch
dunkle kleidung funktioniert wie zum
beispiel diese beduinen demonstrieren
schwarzer stoff absorbiert zwar mehr
sonnenlicht leitet die wärme aber auch
schlechter weiter wichtiger ist dass
viel luft an die haut kommt damit der
schweisgut verdampfen kann
atmungsaktivität ist wichtiger als farbe
drittens finger weg von alkohol und
koffein wer viel schwitzt muss viel
trinken aber eine schöne cola eiscafé
oder ein kühles bier sind
kontraproduktiv
sowohl alkohol als auch koffein haben
einen sogenannten theoretischen effekt
das heißt sie entweder auch dazu gibt es
ein video hier
viertens heißgetränke kühle getränke
kühlen zwar heiße aber auch die
körpertemperatur steigt zwar minimal an
doch der anschließende schweißausbruch
gleich das schnell aus und kühlt den
körper sogar noch ein bisschen mehr ab
als ein kühles getränk fünfter verarscht
ein gehirn minze enthält das molekül
minto inventur aktiviert ein protein
rezeptor im gehirn wodurch für uns kühl
fühlen selbst wenn wir es gar nicht sind
ein treffer ins bonbon oder ein wasser
spree mit ein paar tropfen minzöl kann
für gefühlte kühle sorgen
aber vorsicht das ist nur ein notfall
trick versteuern körper bloß nicht zu
sehr stieß ich will euch etwas wichtiges
sagen
in chili es ist cup es ihnen drin
das ist quasi das gegenteil von menthol
es aktiviert werde rezeptoren so dass
dein gehirn glaubt ihr sei warm
die folge ist schwitzen was wiederum
abkühlt das heißt du denkst dir heiß
aber in wirklichkeit küste durch
schwitzen ab 6
achtung sonnencreme immer schön
eincremen gibt hautkrebs keine chance
das blöde nur sonnencreme beeinträchtigt
das schwitzen also unser kühlsystem
da hilft am ende auch nur sonne meiden
und bitte nicht nachmachen also keinen
schatten hinter autos suchen
bitte lasst euch nicht überfahren vielen
dank miller wenn ihr noch fragen hat
dann schreibt sie in die kommentare und
gleich kommen noch die outtakes
so und jetzt ich trinke was nützt mir
dann voll ins gesicht sieht es nach
schweiß aus weiß ich nicht als er
wirklich mal ein paar runden und block
laufen dann ist sehr wichtig
[Musik]
spinat und schwitzen noch nicht egal wie
machen sie dem wasser